anderson
is 30 years of age six to 215 pounder
out of las vegas
and uh take a look what he has done this
year one and three with a five 180 all
right this is the first time his last
three starts have been against arizona
all of them so it's the first time he's
had a new opponent here in four starts
he's looking forward to tonight seeger
is
homered in double lifetime against tyler
anderson two for six
lifts this one out to right center field
yostremski's going to
take charge and that ends the inning for
the seattle mariners is the the 24 year
old left-hander nick
margavichus take a look at what he's
done he's been a swing man three times
out of the pin four starts they're a
nice job 23 strikeouts against five
walks at 25 and two thirds
two down here comes darren rough here's
the 2-2 again fastball swing at a miss
for strike three and mark avecis strikes
out the side here in the bottom of the
first inning getting yastremski solano
and ruff want to start for nick
margabichus we go to the top half of the
second brings up the veteran brandon
belt
now the stretch and the one-two pitch
fastball swing animus for strike three
that is strikeout number four for nick
margavitches living at the top of the
zone with that fastball and evan
longoria will come up here's the wind-up
and the one-two to longoria swinging a
miss and a change-up strike three and
will retire the side and that is five
strikeouts for margaret's
in the first six batters he is retired
holy smokes what a start for nick we go
to the top of the third hour score the
mariners nothing the giants nothing that
brings up philip irvin hitting ninth
anderson stands squared two home plate
gets the sign the wind-up band now the
delivery swinging a broken back line
drive and it is into left field for a
base hip dives one in front of rough
philip irvin a one out single second hit
tonight for the mariners first time
through the order for tyler anderson a
couple of singles given up plus a walk
runners stay put first and third and
here is kyle lewis 0-1 the pitch is
grounded softly toward short crawford
charges he's got it his throw to first
is just in time to get the speedy lewis
well done so tyler anderson couple big
pitches there after back-to-back singles
gets through it no damage done
back to the top of the order
six of the first seven outs the giants
have made in this game have come by way
of the strikeout so this becomes a more
pressure-filled bat for yastremski
high drive to right
it
is
out of here
ninth of the year
and he's done it again with two strikes
puts the giants ahead three nothing what
he has done in the two-strike count this
year is
remarkable
right-handed hitter against the lefty
tyler anderson in the fourth inning bart
sets the target here's the pitch it is
hit hard on the ground to third scooped
up after a second hop by longoria takes
his time and throws to first for out
number three
torrence hit it hard but right to the
defense so one on and one away and here
is third baseman evan longoria now in a
3-1 count swings and lines one towards
center field it's going to get down for
a base hit so longoria gets to knock in
the run himself flores comes in and
scores it's four nothing giants and now
the bases are loaded rough to third
flores to second and now longoria do up
the one-two pitch swing line drive base
hit right center field ruff is in the
score from third around third flores he
is in the score heading for third is
belt and he's there standing up a
two-run single by evan longoria that's
the second consecutive rbi hit for longo
and the giants have a six-nothing lead
he's done so much over the last two
weeks here's bart he's singled and he's
popped out to right
up the middle and a base hit and here
comes belt and it's seven to nothing an
rbi for joey bart giants had three in
the third one in the fourth and now
three more runs in here in the bottom of
the fifth inning there were two outs and
nobody on
so two down here is kyle seeger the
left-handed hitter who has flied out
now there's a swinging strike three with
a change-up another shutdown inning
that's eight in a row retired by tyler
anderson who has now thrown exactly 100
pitches here's flores
he hooks one down the left field line
and we're going to watch bisabi run and
he has got a low fly going and now
they're going to put up a stop sign
because that's a double for flores
bell goes the other way
and he's going to pick up an rbi
as pasabe scores
so one on one out top of the eighth
here's the stretch and the next offer on
the way swinging a fly ball into right
center field got it in the air over here
stremski and dubon dubon will make the
catch tagging a third more heading home
he slides he's safe and the mariners get
on the board
and there is sacrifice flying number six
on the year for kyle seeger and the
mariners
finally hit the old pay station they
have their first run of the game here in
the top of the eighth oh two outs for
the mariners here in the top of the
ninth inning he's got excellent stuff
the pitch
swing and a miss on a high fastballs he
struck him out and the ball game is over
so the giants win their fifth in a row
well and tyler anderson tonight was
fantastic i mean he pitched through a
walk and an air in the first inning and
then locked it in